tiens d'eau sur mathieu ah ça c'est
qu'aussi ouais ça ça me fait un dos qui
pose problème au sein de l'équipe
dossier vous sur quelqu'un de la table
le pur benjamin castaldi balance bien
d'un dossier sur kelly mais que je garde
pour plus tard non maintenant du tout
maintenant
maintenant mon gardien pour plus tard
ici le big bang sim a lâché d'affaires
enfin enfin mon frère est sur les rangs
votre frère geoffrey ont été financés la
de votre frère à bord il a 27 ans soit
il mit sur kevin eiben non il est pas
encore
ferriol brad pitt on dirait moi d'abord
et après boîtes scellées m 2 sur wii
mais c'est vraiment comment ça si vous
avez les deux même pas y aller mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais la mer
cela amène un maire ou un nerf optique
il a pas dit non mais n'a jamais
beaucoup plus beau quoi j'aimerais
beaucoup plus bas depuis 2000 ans
répartis sur pic de bic
le bon roi maléfique
franchement il a pas ton daniel basset
dernier j'ai pas trop faire de moi quoi
ces politiques ça donne un coup bah
ouais ouais ouais bof c'est quoi votre
style de mec vous n'y est pas giovanni
tacchelli ou daniel ayala tu peux pas
tout espoir
il est trop beau quoi c'est vrai c'est
votre came alors qu'elle y c'est vrai ce
dont il est très beau et puis j'ai vu en
vrai il encore plus haut et alors mais
l'essai on va voir on mange ensemble ce
week end normalement ombre à balad ruz
j'ai dit là il ferme sa gueule
le pauvre n'y est jamais très beau c'est
gentil mais j'ai passé mon week-end avec
kelly ann on était chez moi elle va
passer à un papy il arrive à passer un
maire à 6 alors ça va il ya un os dicale
juste endroit oui voilà c'est tout non
je te dire ce que vous en êtes vous sur
quelqu'un ou parce qu'on fait un petit
dossard est-ce que pardon sur quelqu'un
oui alors j'hésite à parce que je sais
pas si c'est la bonne pour les deux
sessions sont fous dit je peux pas
vraiment vous soyez bien sûr regardez
lille a dit le dos on s'en fout bon ok
alors balances ton pote au lancement
mais divine m'a fait des petites
confidences c'est quoi euh non mais non
rappelle fort à propos de sirène non mr
[Applaudissements]
exiger la présence de mon avocat voilà
voilà sais pas si je pouvais le dire
mais voilà livide m'a avoué qu'elle
avait un petit rush pour vous serrer mon
nom me font rien du tout de tous mais
kelly mais c'est ma copine divine fait
mais alors alors les deux monnaies
gerald et l'amicale cyril un moi aussi
ça me canadas amical ça me rassure c'est
we can mais n'est pas amicale du tout
non mais attendez non mais on est on est
on est on est tannés de maillot on est
tous les deux voilà hamac et bien sûr
mais ce à quoi comment son équipe mais
qu'est ce qu'elle veut celle là c'est
satan de la chine n'empêchera mais la
lorraine
je plains votre frère et moi vraiment si
non non non atrash en tout bien tout
honneur s'est alors basée au virage
alors moi je vous trouve magnifique ici
franchement vous auriez pu être mon
délire
approche c'est malheureusement vous
n'êtes pas mais ça tombe bien les choses
daniel ça va tomber
ça va très bien ton délire mon prêt du
tout haut eh bien les blonds toi ça
arrangeait bien les bras un brin de
grands barrages pas très petit mais
j'suis pas très grand am et tais toi le
petit mesure combien toi mais 58
mais il faut quand même que tu le vois
encore tomber un minimum combien avec 70
78 m c'est la vie donc quand je fais un
mètre cinquante
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mouloud sa magnifique et l'ouverture
c'est pas votre délire alors non mais
j'ai un autre petit dossier quoi ces
barrettes amoureuse de lui et mathilde
non prévient jean-michel alors qu'il est
lui dit est-ce que vous avez un doute
sur quelqu'un d'absolument et un gros
dos si j'ose dire
chaque fois un bagne concert de jean
michel mr pas bon alors dans ses sorties
de fin alors c'est quoi c'est un très
très gros dos jean-mi m'a confié andy
terre en été en loge elle m'a confié
s'être fait retirer un peu de graisse de
son popotin pour avoir l'insérer dans
son engin pour qu'il soit un peu mais
comme vous tu as aimé
[Rires]
jab à écouter vont persister avait été
vrai j'aurais été carrément hors norme
comme le monde me tombe dit que c'est
faux non c'est pas la regarder
est ce que vous avez à dos sur quelqu'un
alain jomy ce que vous avez à dos sur
quelqu'un en vrai jean michel maire se
veut grossir le sac était vraiment
s'attaquer
[Applaudissements]
évidemment pendant vu leurs gammes ça ne
vous concernera jamais mais pour les
gens qui veulent le faire il faut faire
attention parce que ça ne dure que six
mois à lui les fennecs et moi non et oui
parce que c'est ma vraie grèce qu'on a
appris moi c'est pas de l'acide
hyaluronique pour la grèce que vous me
le font non ça coûte 3500 euros au bout
de 6 à 8 mois les aventures joli nom et
c'est jolie bimbo
donc il faut se balader le cisi à l'air
dans ce rôle
bref c'est vraiment amusant t12 faut pas
attendre d'accord très bien merci
est ce que vous avez à dos sur quelques
agents me traitait en train de choquer
la non daniel non et c'est vrai nom
joseph
mais c'est vrai la paix une plastie ça
coûte 3500 euros
bon voilà c'est c'est très bien fait
c'est une petite canule dans la fête et
non pas ce qu'ils ont fait c'est parce
que sa fille allait laisser vous avez un
doute sur qui vient d'eux sur kelly 1 an
1/2 sur kenny à dos sacs à dos à dos
assez gourmand quoi elle aime les tartes
aux fraises
elle aime les merengues à mal alors j'ai
pas envie de tizé sur le scoop sur le
dos de maximum parce que je suis sûr que
c'est pourri loup c'est pourri oui bien
sûr comme à chaque fois est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est blanc oum seyfoullah il
est vexé
mieux vaut que je le fasse mal à les
lignes à sebourg systématiquement de
ghettos avant chaque émission
elle va récupérer des madeleines des
bonbons elle se goinfrent en deux temps
trois la vilaine vous avez bien fait de
petits 0 est ce que vous êtes ado sur
quelqu'un pas que quoi tient d'eau sur
mathieu as assez croustillant ouais ça
ça me fait un dos qui pose problème au
sein de l'équipe d'en bas à ses bas ses
nuits douces qui pose problème alors
peut-être quoi mon talent peut-être non
ça on l'aurait vu depuis quelques
semaines
art savoir que matthieu delormeau a
repris la confiance ah oui mais c'est
vrai que là c'est vrai voilà vous êtes
d'accord et il a une nouvelle tactique
que je vais vous exposer parce que vous
êtes du sûr au détriment de tout le
monde
moi je suis dupe mais oui après les
évictions moi je suis dit hé oui vous
allez voir que devant moi honnêtement
vous allez voir pourquoi
après les émissions vous restez discuter
avec le public oui non remontants loges
on se change et on s'en va et mathieu
lui il se démaquiller il se cache et
qu'est-ce qui fait il attend que vous
remontiez on vous entend remonter vous
parlez qui sort de sa cachette il faut
sur vous ayez vous dit j'ai vu plein de
fois a vu bébé j'ai encore fait une
bonne émission soir voilà et vous vous
lui répondez parce que vous êtes d'un
naturel gentil oui c'est vrai mon bébé
ouais et l'abc revient nous voir en
loges et les connards cyril m'a dit que
vous étiez nul heureusement que j'ai
sauvé l'émission est chez moi mais je
vois pas où ils inepties la mer si mon
chéri on s'accroche et de chiffres
l'élèvera regarder le écoutez le non non
non non c'est vrai qu'il fait ça mais
oui je confirme simplement merci vous et
mathieu comment vous entendez ça va
aller à mon pote je suis là je suis
assad connaître son prénom sur l'échelle
du boulevard de 1dt largement à 16 merci
à tous et j'ai vous aussi proposer le
fascicule de maxime c'est que sa peine
ne te laissent plus marcher sur les pas
bons maxi quelle répartie bim c'était
prévu danielle hawey et moi j'adore de
leur beau non c'est vrai mais je la dois
vraiment awel loi est super sympa gentil
et tout ah oui mais vous l'avez vous
êtes sûr que vous confondez pas c'est
pas de préférer matthieu delormeau ah
ouais ouais c'est vrai
[Musique]